When using matrices, the way we tell points from vectors is by putting a 1 or a
0 for the last coordinate. This also works rather nicely as an operation check
when using point and vector math. For example, if we add 2 vectors, the fourth
coordinates add up to be 0, which means a vector. If we subtract 1 vector from
another, the same thing works out. The fourth coordinate is 0 so it's a vector.
If we had a point and a vector, we get a point because the fourth coordinate is
1. If we subtract 1 point from another we get a vector showing the movement
needed to go from the second point to the first. This fourth coordinate also
acts as a way to check against doing illegal things. If you add two points, this
normally has no real meaning. The fourth coordinate is 2, which is a tip off
that something is not right. Now that we have this fourth coordinate, we can
multiply points and vectors by a 4 by 4 matrix.